what is going on everybody welcome to
another python 3 basics video in this
video we're now going to be discussing
the concept
of global and local variables
so when users start using functions they
quickly get a little confused when it
comes to global and local variables
and they get this you know dreaded you
know variable not defined uh even when
they clearly see that it is defined or
so they think so these terms of global
and local corresponds to a variable's
reach
uh within a script or a program so a
global variable is a variable that can
be accessed anywhere a local variable
the opposite
means it can only be accessed within its
you know environment or its frame
so a local variable cannot be accessed
globally inherently anyways
and
a
global variable can be right but you've
got to turn it into a global variable
and some people have a misunderstanding
of what a global variable actually is
so let's go ahead and give some examples
so if you if you haven't committed this
to memory no problem i think actually
seeing
um helps unders i hope ciao understand
so
x equals six this variable has no parent
function
but it's actually not a global variable
it just so happens that it's committed
to memory before any sort of function or
anything is called so for example we can
say define example
and
we can actually say
you know z equals 5
print z
and that's totally fine and we can call
example
and as we uh expect it's going to print
5. so we know that works
but what uh starts giving trouble to
people
is instead of let's get rid of this and
let's say you want to print
x
well we run this function
and we see
we can print x so we were able to access
x
from this function and
what happens is users naively think that
because they were able to access it now
they're able to play with this variable
let's say so print
x plus
five
okay
so they start playing with it they see
okay well we can start modifying it and
all this cool cool cool so we have you
know access to this but the problem is
when they start to do something like
this x plus equals 6
and they go to run it
and you see unbound local error local
variable x is referenced before
assignment
yet this makes people just pull out the
hair because uh first of all they never
got their they didn't get the things
printed
so they're freaking out like so they
didn't get the you know confirmation
here because when you get rid of this
it does print them
it's only you only get that error
whenever
uh you try to actually do something like
add six to that variable
and so they start pulling out their hair
because
up till now they thought they were
getting away with doing that but the
problem is
x is not a global variable so
uh there's a few ways that you can get
around this obviously the easiest thing
to do would be to convert x to a global
variable so to do that you type out
global space x
and what that does is it's notifying
python that hey guys x is actually a
global variable
and so now what we can do
is print
x and then we can even do x plus equals
5
print
x so now we go to run this sure enough 6
11 everything worked we were able to use
our global variable
now that's it for global variables but
a lot of teachers you're going to find
or maybe you work for a company or
something
and the
cto says uh nobody gets to use global
functions uh or i mean global variables
don't use them so some people don't like
the idea of using global variables
there's actually you know a couple of
things you can do to get around this um
one one way that people will do it is
the following they might say global
globex equals x because we already know
we can access x we just can't modify it
so then you could print
globex and then we could do globex plus
equals five and print
uh globex
and we're able to do that six eleven so
we get the same output that we wanted
but maybe we're not happy with that
because when we do this
now we've changed variables here and
also globex is a local variable and so
we're not able to access globex outside
of this function so say we've got
multiple functions and we want them to
work together
we're not going to be able to do that so
what do you do instead well
generally what you're going to see is
instead
you'll get everything up to this point
no problem but instead what we'll have
what users will do is they're going to
return
globex
with example so when this function is
run it's going to return a value and
what this means is it's almost like when
you do five plus five in python what
five plus five does is it returns ten
and so by that same token what we can do
is if you wanted to set a value to five
plus five or a set of very five plus
five equal to a variable what you would
do is you would say maybe x equals the
function of example
and now
print
whoops
print x
save and run that we see that we were
able to do that so this is one way that
you can actually end up modifying this
within the main loop let's say
um without using global variables
because again some people really just
are very anal about global variables so
uh hopefully that helps some of you guys
out uh especially with the whole uh
accessing this local variable but then
not being able to modify it
so hopefully save you guys from pulling
out your hair uh this is something that
did give me some trouble when i was
starting out so hopefully i save you
guys some of that
uh so hopefully you guys enjoyed as
always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions and
until next time